the number of people who have died after
testing positive for kovat 19 in UK
hospitals has risen now that total
stands at nine thousand eight hundred
and seventy five those figures that come
to us from the Department of Health
represent an increase of 917 on the
number of victims that we reported
yesterday one of those in the latest set
of numbers was only 11 years old we've
also heard from NHS England today now
they have reported another 823 people
who have died with coronavirus London
has again more than any other region 208
people they're confirmed to have lost
their lives and in the Midlands there
were another 165 reported deaths in
Scotland another 47 deaths have been
recorded there that takes the total in
Scotland to 542 public health Wales
meanwhile says 36 more deaths have been
reported there that takes the Welsh
total to 351 and Northern Ireland's
public health agency it says that
another 15 people have died there taking
the total to 107 has more on all of this
for us from the newsroom Laura as we
approach a grim landmark of nearly
10,000 people to have died in UK
hospital said the true total presumably
much greater than that it's a time to
stop and reflect his net on the number
of lives lost yes it certainly is these
are huge figures today's figure of 917
deaths in the UK is considerable but it
is slightly less than the same figure
reported yesterday which stood 980 now
there are lots of things to take into
consideration when we look at these
figures this does not mean that we are
reaching a peak necessary that the peak
is passing what we're in even in the
middle of a peak purely because we know
that we've had a bank holiday yesterday
on Good Friday what we've been seeing
after a week end to the Monday figures
following a Sunday have always been
slightly lower so I think that certainly
needs to be taken in
consideration and of course you're right
what we're talking about here is a
number of people who have tested
positive and died while in hospital and
we know that the actual figure is likely
to be much much higher because this does
not take into account the number of
people who are dying in the community so
this will include people who died in
within the care sector in residential
homes in care homes for example if we
look at the number of people getting the
tests as well that's interesting so we
know that 18,000 and 91 people were
tested in the UK and that is slightly
lower than the previous day and of
course nowhere near that 100,000 goal
that the health secretary has set for
the end of the month if we look
particular at the figures coming out of
England they are slightly down on the
previous day but saying things are down
when we're talking about 823 deaths this
is a slightly strange way of putting it
we do know that they were aged between
eleven years old and a hundred and two
and that 33 of them had no underlying
health conditions I think what we need
to ask now is what do these figures tell
us it's very hard to compare day on day
figures to look at overall trends is far
more important and perhaps we're still
not far enough into the look down to get
a bigger picture but the one tiny
glimmer of hope and these sobering
lehigh figures is the fact that the rate
are of daily deaths seems to be slowing
down slightly so if you look at the
figures from the start of April from the
2nd of April the number of deaths was
doubling every 3 days we now know it's
doubling every 5 days but like I say to
have a death figure of 917 in one day
that's 917 families friends and
colleagues all left grieving and
mourning at the moment it is not to be
underestimated at this point